can we mention churchill briefly because
uh he is one of the
um
you could make a case for him being one
of the
great representers or great figures
historically of the western civilization
yes and then there's a lot of people
uh from not a lot
i know i have like three friends and one
one of them happens to be from london
and they they say that he's a a uh um
not a good person
so listen this friend would not discuss
i just this is an opinion poll of the
three friends but i do know that there's
quite a bit you know there's a backlash
going on at the moment at the moment and
in general there's a spirit like
reflecting on on the darker sides of
some of these historical figures like
challenging history through
it's it's not just critical race theory
it's it's it's challenging
history through well uh are
the people we
think of us heroes
what are their flaws and are they in
fact villains that are convenient
um
sort of uh were there at the right time
to accidentally do the right thing
accidentally
i hope this isn't the
representative
fair estimation of your friend in
london's views no she's going to be
quite mad at this but i didn't say the
name so it could be any friends it could
be but we know this is she canada
well see i i
i'm giving that away well that's with of
course i would not um i made that up
completely it's it's all
just like my girlfriend in canada she's
completely a figment of my imagination
nevertheless
winston churchill uh is somebody i mean
just looking at
reading the rise and fall of the third
reich is an incredible figure that um
that to me
so much of world war ii is marked
leading up to the wars marked by
stunning amounts of cowardice by
political leaders and
it's fascinating to watch hear
this
person clearly with the drinking and a
smoking problem
was it was i didn't understand why
that's the negative no i didn't say you
see yeah you throw it in as if it is no
well it's it's called humor i'll explain
it to you one day what that means but
he still explained dry him
[Laughter]
he stood up
he
he stood up to what we now see as evil
when at the time it was not so obvious
to see
um
[Music]
you know so that that's that's just a
fascinating figure of western
civilization i'd love to get your
comments the real criticisms i mean
it's making you drinking the real
christmas of of church are quite easy to
to sum up and i do so in the war in the
west station i say these are the things
that they now use against him uh didn't
do enough to avert the bengal famine in
1943 for instance that's been shot down
by numerous historians including indian
historians
uh in the middle of the war in the
middle of a world war churchill did what
he could to get grain supplies diverted
um from australia to into bengal
the famine was appalling it was caused
by a typhoon it was not caused by
winston churchill
um and the idea that some
basically indian nationalist historians
have pumped out in recent years
and just
anti-churchill figures
that
he actually wanted indians to die is um
his just total calumny
and when people claim some people claim
that i mean there was a few
fairly ignorant scholars but
nevertheless with some credentials who
claimed that churchill wanted the indian
population to right basically be
genocided and this is complete nonsense
not least by the fact that during the
period which
in question
indian population boomed
um
so
that that's one of the main ones
another one is that he had um some views
that we now had regard as racist he
definitely regarded races as being of
different characters
um and that they were superior races and
the the as it were the white european
was a superior culture
um
uh
he was born in victorian england so he
had some victorian attitudes
um
these are things in the negative side of
the ledger and as with all history you
should have a negative and a positive
side of the ledger positive side of the
ledger includes he almost certainly did
more than any one human being to save
the world from nazism
so that should count as something
and one of the reasons i talk about
churchill in this regard is this is to
stress that
if you get
i'm not trying to stop anyone doing
history
at all i don't think the revisionism of
recent years about churchill or the
founding fathers of america or anyone
else is
anything i want to stop i find it
interesting i find it interesting not
least because it's so sloppy on
occasions but i find it interesting it's
important and we should be able to see
people in the round
but
that includes recognizing the positive
side of the ledger
and if you can't recognize that side
you're doing something else you're doing
something else it's not history
it's um some form of politicking of a
very particular kind and i think it's
the same thing with the founding fathers
there are some people for instance
certainly since the 90s who have pushed
the sally hemmings thomas jefferson
story to show that thomas jefferson was
some kind of brute as a result um
you know we see
jefferson's statue being removed from
the council chamber the city was sitting
in last november by council members who
said that thomas jefferson no longer
represents our values if you can't re if
you can't recognize greatness of thomas
jefferson and that he had flaws
i mean
that's not a grown-up debate
you